2021 was a record year for
cryptocurrency the market cap hit three
trillion dollars the sec approved its
first bitcoin etf and nfts hit million
dollar values it appears safe to say
digital currency is now mainstream here
are five numbers that really defined
crypto this year and what they mean
going into 2022 the first 11. that's the
estimated portion of gold's 11 trillion
dollar market cap that's been reached by
bitcoin when bitcoin hit its most its
all-time high of over 68 000 just about
a month ago
bitcoin's total market cap which was
over a trillion dollars itself reached
11 of all of gold which was the highest
that it had ever been
and uh and given that bitcoin is seen in
many circles as an inflation hedge uh
store value a digital gold to gold 2.0
a lot of people are paying attention to
that metric and seeing if it's going to
climb in the years ahead
although bitcoin is often described as
digital gold it still trades wildly
which may not make it the most
attractive choice for someone looking
for a worry-free asset and with the
federal reserve looking to accelerate
its tapering schedule in response to
rising inflation bitcoin may need a new
value proposition in 2022 that doesn't
rely on easy money from washington next
is the number 123.02
that's the estimated yearly energy
consumption of bitcoin miners in
terawatt hours according to the bitcoin
electricity consumption index at
cambridge university this is about the
same amount of energy used by
middle-income countries such as
argentina and norway this has opened up
a debate about bitcoin's carbon
footprint and what can be done to
mitigate it
other networks such as ethereum and
zcash which were based on similar energy
intensive uh what's known as consensus
mechanisms are switching or advocating a
switch to something that's much more
energy efficient but bitcoin is the
bitcoin community is much more obstinate
and and they really feel that switching
would harm the overall value proposition
there's two things i'd point out um
which i find kind of annoying we're
comparing a a payment rail and asset
class as one
um with countries um which is almost as
close to an apples and oranges
comparison as you can get um if you look
at something that's a little more
comparable like the global financial
system um or the
the cost to mine actual gold
the comparison is almost impossible to
make and the reason why it's almost
impossible to make is because we don't
have the numbers on that the global
financial system does not share its
energy consumption uh the gold producers
of the world do not share how much it
costs to mine their gold
i like to think that if you did an
apples-to-apples comparison there the
cost of bitcoin wouldn't be quite as as
bad as some of those other
older and more accurate comparisons the
third number is 233
276. that's the floor price in us
dollars for a board ape yacht club
monkey part of a collection of nfts
which really took off this year despite
one key criticism
anyone can right click and save if they
really want it but if you want to prove
ownership of it it's going to cost you
six figures
and and to me that shows one the
frothiness of the industry but also the
excitement and in some ways it does a
disservice because it also hides a lot
of really interesting innovation and
work that's being done behind the scenes
to make nfts much more useful and a real
critical part of our digital economy
moving forward
the fourth number is six billion three
hundred and thirty two million three
hundred and eighty thousand that's the
total amount in u.s dollars for funding
raised by cryptocurrency companies over
the 10 largest investment rounds this
year two of the biggest were crypto
service provider nydig raising one
billion dollars and ftx raising a 900
million dollar series b the fifth number
is 12 billion
that's about how many us dollars were
raised in 2021 to build the metaverse a
virtual reality layer to the internet
leading the pack was epic games which
hauled in one billion dollars to ensure
its games weren't displaced by open
source competitors built on top of
blockchains the metaverse and the nft
world are also beginning to converge
in april forbes sold the first nft
magazine cover for 333
called masters of the metaverse it
depicted the winklevoss twins who later
raised 400 million dollars to build out
their cryptocurrency exchange and invest
in a number of metaverse related
projects
they had secretly or not so secretly but
discreetly been investing um in the the
building blocks of an internet that
didn't require centralized servers um
which ended up being what we now
consider fundamental to the existence of
this metaverse or a
a video game like layer of the internet
uh where instead of going to websites
you can go to virtual locations
tyler and cameron really position
themselves as early investors in the
space by taking a lead in the nft
category
i like to think of nfts as more than
just digital assets but the building
blocks of this virtual world for years
to come
[Music]